COMMITTEE ON INSURANCE WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON
IN RESPONSE TO THE COLBERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. A
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING
ESSENTIAL HEARINGS AND HAS MAKE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS NORMAL
JUST AN ORDER TWENTY. THE THEY
CONTINUE TO HAVE ACCESS TO LET
PROCESS WHILE CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC AND OUR EMPLOYEES. SB
COMPLY WITH THOSE ORDERS WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL. WITH SOME
OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING IN DEBATE
REMOTELY WITH THE USE OF A
VIDEO COM AND SYSTEM. FOR
MEMBERS WHO WILL BE ATTENDING
REMOTELY TODAY PLEASE MEET YOUR
PHONES OUR COMPUTERS ARE IT
PERSONNEL A MUTE AND UNMUTE THE
VIDEO SERVICE WHEN YOU WISH TO
SPEAK. THIS WILL GREATLY EIGHT
AND ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK I ASK THAT EVERY TIME
YOU HAVE A COMMENT OR QUESTION
HE IS THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THIS PROGRAM. ONCE
RECOGNIZED THESE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF THEN PROCEED. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVEN'T
MADE IT MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
INTO THE CHAMBER AN OVERFLOW
ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
ADDITIONALLY WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO CANNOT BE
HERE PERCENT WISH TO TOP FIVE
K. FOR ALL. THOSE WHICH TO PUT
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT HERE IN A MOMENT.
TODAY'S PART NUMBER IS.
1-844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO FOUR NINE FIVE
THREE EIGHT FOUR. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT TO A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
THAT THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAINED A
COURT. HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY.
AT ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS
IN AS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IT IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY
BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE JESTING TO
THE USE OF NEW ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT SO I
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. WE HAVE FOR MEASURES TO
CONSIDER TODAY. SB EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR DODD AND
SB TWELVE TWENTY TWO BY SENATOR
DRAWS ON WILL BE PRESENT.
ARCHITECT CALENDAR CONSIST OF
TWO BILLS SB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE.
THE BILL AND SB ELEVEN NINETY
TWO BY STATE BRADFORD. EIGHT
FIFTY BILL SB NINE SIXTY ONE BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ WILL NOT BE
HEARD TODAY BUT INSTEAD IS
BEING AMENDED INTO THE
COMMITTEES OMNIBUS BILL I WANT
TO THANK SENATOR GONZALEZ. AND
STOP FOR WORKING WHETHER
COMMITTEE TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND LIMITING CONTACT
WHILE MAKING SURE THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE CONTINUES TO
MOVE THROUGH THE PROCESS. DUE
TO THE CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF THE HEARING.
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS. AND
YOU CLEANING PROTOCOLS
COMMITTEES WILL INSTITUTE TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY. ACCORDING
TO EACH SIDE. I'M SORRY
ACCORDINGLY EACH SIDE WILL ONLY
BE PERMITTED. A TOTAL THREE
MINUTES ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. BEFORE WE BEGIN LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM I LIKE TO
REMIND MEMBERS THAT MICROPHONES
ARE TURNED ON REMOTELY SO
PLEASE POTS TAKE A MOMENT.
BEFORE YOU SPEAK INTO THE
MICROPHONE. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. RUBIO HERE RUBIO
PRESENT JONES AIR JONES PRESENT
ARCHULETA HERE ARCHULETA
PRESENT DODD. HERE DODD PRESENT
GALGIANI PRESENT GALGIANI
PRESENT GLAZER PRESENT GLAZER
PRESENT HI SO. TWITTER PRESENT
MITCHELL HERE MITCHELL PRESENT
MORE LOCK RESIDENT LIKE PRESENT
PORTANTINO THERE PORTANTINO
PRESENT BROUGHT. HERE WHAT
PRESIDENT MANAGER WE HAVE A
QUORUM. THE SECRETARY NO THE
CAR HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED- BUT
BEFORE WE GO FORWARD I WOULD
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE
TO MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY FROM THEIR DISTRICTS
OFFICE THAT DAY WILL BE
PARTICIPATING IN COMMENTS
QUESTIONS AND DEBATE TODAY BUT
WILL NOT BE VOTING. THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES AND CENTER BOARD
JUST FOR JOINING US REMOTELY
TODAY AND LET YOUR ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING
REMOTE WHILE STAYING SAFE AT
HOME. HOW WE WILL MOVE FOR WITH
THE FIRST BILL I WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME UP FIRST SENATOR DRAWS
ON TO PRESENT SB TWELVE TWENTY
TWO. SENATOR WELCOME. AND WHEN
YOU'RE READY YOU MAY PROCEED.
OKAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- AND
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB TWELVE
TWENTY TWO. THIS BILL REQUIRES
PRIVATE FOR PROFIT PRISONS AND
DETENTION FACILITIES TO ME ONE
MEET AND MAINTAIN INSURANCE
REQUIREMENTS INCLUDING GENERAL
LIABILITY AUTOMOBILE LIABILITY
UMBRELLA LIABILITY AND WORKERS
COMPENSATION. AS WELL AS COMPLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
MINIMUM JAIL STANDARDS THE
FEDERAL PERFORMANCE BASED
DETENTION STANDARDS AND ALL
WILL BE A STATE LAW AND LOCAL
BUILDING ZONING HEALTH SAFETY
BAR STATUTES. THIS IS AN
REGULATIONS TO DO BUSINESS
CALIFORNIA YEAH. THE BILL
REQUIRES INSURANCE COMPANIES
PROVIDING COVERAGE TO THESE
FACILITIES TO BE ADMITTED
INSURANCE CARRIERS AUTHORIZED
TO DO BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT THE INSURANCE COMPANY
TURMAN. PROFIT PRISON OR THE
FACILITY THAT THEY ARE
CONTRACTED WITH FAILS TO COMPLY
WITH THE STANDARDS I JUST
MENTIONED. THE THREE
CORPORATIONS OWNED THE PRIVATE
FOR PROFIT PRISONS AND
DETENTION FACILITIES AND IN
CALIFORNIA. THE MAJOR DETENTION
FACILITIES BASED IN CALIFORNIA
OUR OTHER LLANTO MISS OF THEIR
THEIR IMPERIAL REGIONAL AND
WHAT TIME IS A DETENTION
FACILITIES. THESE FOR PROPERTY
FACILITIES HAVE A LONG RUNNING
HIS A PORK IN. THE FACILITIES
IN RESPONSE CALIFORNIA'S TAKEN
A DEFINITIVE STANCE TO IMPROVE
THE CONDITIONS. IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SENATOR LOTT A PASSED
AS BE TWELVE EIGHTY NINE THAT
PROHIBIT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
FROM CONTRACTING FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AS OF JANUARY
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN SB THIRTY TO PROHIBIT
THE OPERATION OF FOR PROFIT
PRIVATE DETENTION FACILITY-
AFTER JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND AFOREMENTIONED COME IS REST
TO ENTER INTO A SERIES OF
CONTRACTS. IN AN AMP. TO SIR.
AB THIRTY TWO MEANWHILE MEN AND
WOMEN ARE STILL DETAINED IN A
POOR AND CONDITIONS THERE ARE
NUMEROUS REPORTS OF HORRIFIC
CONDITIONS AND ABUSIVE
TREATMENT OF PEOPLE IT THE TECH
POSSIBILITIES. INCLUDING SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND ABUSE FREQUENT USE
OF SOLITARY CONFINEMENT USE OF
VISIT FOR SENATE ADEQUATE
MEDICAL CARE. OF IT DETENTION
FACILITIES IS THREATENED THAT
MORE THAN EVER DUE TO A COLBERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC REPORTS ON
THE CONDITION OF DETENTION
FACILITIES DURING THE PANDEMIC
THE PICK THE LACK OF RELIABLE
ACCESS TO SOAP SANITIZER AND
OTHER PRO FRENCH PERSONAL
PROTECTION EQUIPMENT AND ALLEN
THE SPACE FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE.
AND INCLUDES A CAL SEVENTY
DETAINEES SCHERING FIVE BARS OF
SOAP AND GUARDS COMING IN AND
OUT OF THE DORMS WITHOUT THE PP
MASKS OR GLOVES. AND I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE EXCELLENT WORK.
ON THE COMMITTEE IN YOUR
ANALYSIS OF THIS BILL IN THAT
ANALYSIS YOU CITE AN EXAMPLE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE CALIFORNIA FARM
INSURANCE WHICH SHOWS HOW
PREVENTION VIA AN IN SHARON'S
ARRANGEMENT. CAN BE USED TO
FORCE IMPROVEMENTS. QUOTE
ACCORDING TO THE SPONSOR IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN THE CALIFORNIA
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY
THREATENED TO REVOKE THE CITY
OF WHEN DALE'S LIABILITY
INSURANCE. UNLESS CITY HALL AND
ITS POLICE DEPARTMENT TOOK
SUBSTANTIVE STEPS TO TACKLE
INTERNAL CORRUPTION THE CITY
WAS GIVEN EIGHT ITEMS TO FIX IN
EIGHTEEN MONTHS. THE CITY OF A
GOT ON A PATH TOWARD OVER HOW
IT'S DYSFUNCTIONAL DEPARTMENT.
CENTERS THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL IT WILL APPLY TO FOR
PROFIT FACILITIES ENGAGED IN
SEVERAL. ACTION AND HELLO THE
TENTH. OF WITH MAY I HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE CO
SPONSORS OF SB TWELVE TWENTY
TWO MICHAEL MARTINEZ FROM THE
OFFICE OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA AND
CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ- FROM THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS TO SPEAK AND ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. MISTER
MARTINEZ CITY WISH TO SPEAK.
YOU MAY DO SO AT THIS TIME
WELCOME. THANK YOU TO RUBIO AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MIKE
MARTINEZ HERE BEHALF OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
COMMISSIONER LOT IT IS VERY
PROUD TO BE A SPONSOR THIS
MEASURE. WITH THE PERSON FOR
MAY IMMIGRANT. WANT TO THANK
CENTER A FOR SHIP IN OFFERING
THIS MEASURE. WE DO ASK FOR
YEARS OF THIS MEASURE BECAUSE
THIS BILL IS NEEDED NOW TO HOLD
PRIVATE FOR PROFIT PRISONS AND
DETENTION FACILITY IS IN OUR
STATE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
CONTINUED LACK COMPLIANCE.
STANDARDS OF DECENCY AND THEIR
CONTINUED DISREGARD TO PROVIDE
SAFE HUMANE CONDITIONS FOR
THOUSANDS OF DETAINED
INDIVIDUALS IN THESE FACILITIES.
AS THE BILL'S AUTHOR JUST
STATED POOR SUBSTANDARD MEDICAL
TREATMENT LEADING TO DEATHS OF
PEOPLE. THE DETENTION BLOCK OF
ACCESS TO LEGAL SERVICES
LEADING TO VIOLATIONS OF CIVIL
RIGHTS AND OTHER LIFE
THREATENING CONDITIONS.
CONTINUE TO PLAGUE THESE
PRIVATE FOR PROFIT PRISONS AND
DETENTION FACILITIES BECAUSE
THEY PERSISTENTLY FAILED TO
MEET. MINIMUM STATE AND FEDERAL
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS.
THIS BILL IS- IS STRONGLY
SUPPORTED BY COMMISSIONER LOT
OF BECAUSE IT WOULD REQUIRE
COMPLIANCE OF APPROPRIATE
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
DETENTION HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS BY THESE ENTITIES
OTHERWISE WE BELIEVE FAILURE OF
THESE. BY THE FOR PRISONS AND
DETENTION CENTERS TO MEET THESE
BASIC STANDARDS WOULD CREATE AN
UNACCEPTABLE LOSS RISK OF LOSS
FOR ADMITTED INSURANCE
COMPANIES TO CONTINUE TO WRITE
LIABILITY MEDICAL PRACTICE
WORKERS COMPENSATION ANOTHER
COVERAGE FOR THESE FACILITIES.
IN CLOSING THIS BILL SHOULD
PROVIDE A POWERFUL MOTIVATION
FOR THESE ENTITIES TO ADHERE TO
THESE STANDARDS PAUL ALSO
ENSURING THAT THESE FACILITIES
MAINTAIN COMPREHENSIVE
INSURANCE COVERAGE BECAUSE MOST
IMPORTANTLY WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT IS TO ENSURE THAT BASIC
OFF FIFTY HUMAN RIGHT. WAS WERE
MADE ALL OF TO SEND THE STATE
ARE PROTECTED THANK YOU AN
ASTEROID. THANK YOU AS A
REMINDER OUR GIVING THREE
MINUTES TO SIDE IS THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT YOU MAY DO SO
AT THIS TIME. IS THERE ANYONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY WISHING TO
SPEAK. NOW WHAT MODERATOR
PLEASE PROP THOSE- ON THE LINE
IF THEY WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. I AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS SPECIALIST BOXES
WHICH ARE THE COALITION RIGHT
CALIFORNIA VOTERS IN A LIGHT
BUT THEY SURE AND REPRESENTING
ABOUT FAMILY AND WORKERS SURE
THIS PROPERTY AFTER THREE
O'CLOCK ON TO LOOK FOR
DETENTION CENTERS ON CONTINUE
TO A MAIN HEALTH CONDITION I'M
NOT SAFETY SIGN A NOTATION OF
HIGHER THE YOU TO LEGAL
CURRENTLY. TRINA COME OUT. IN
CASE. THE FOUR ELEVEN AND
AREN'T YOU CAN NOT LAW BUT A
LOT SELECT THE CARE AND
TREATMENT THIS INCLUDES THE
START OF THE MAN JUST BECOME UP
AND LOCK THE BY BUSTER
DETENTION HERE. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HOW THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE RETURNS I AM. WAS
SHOULD BE HOWEVER THE OF LOS.
TO ENSURE ALL PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ON PLATE AND I'M NOT ANOTHER BY
LAW THAT IS WHY WE ASK FOR YOUR
ENTER YOUR WILL FOR THE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT NOW MONTEREY
PLEASE PROMPT THOSE WAITING TO.
IN SUPPORT BY PHONE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL BY PHONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
YOU'RE USING A SPEAKER PHONE
PLEASE PICK UP THE HANDSET
BEFORE PRESSING THE NUMBERS AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PRESS ONE AND THEN. ZERO WE DO
HAVE THE LINE OF MIA. ON THE
LINE ONE MOMENT PLEASE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY A- I JUST WANT TO
REMIND BEFORE WE MOVE ON OVER
TO PLEASE ONLY STATE YOUR NAME
AND YOUR POSITION THANK YOU.
AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE
I WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE GETS TO
SPEAK SO GIVE THEM A FEW MORE
SECONDS TO GET THE SYSTEM GOING.
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
CLARIFY HOW MANY PEOPLE WE HAVE
WAITING TO SPEAK. WE JUST HAVE
MY IN ROOM ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ANGER ON A FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU FOR THAT. HAVING HEARD FROM
ALL SUPPORTERS ARE THERE
ANYMORE WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK. MODERATOR ONE MORE TIME
TO ENSURE THAT A ONE HOUSE
ABILITY TO SPEAK ON THIS ISSUE.
CAN YOU PLEASE CHECK IF THERE'S
ANYBODY ELSE LATER OF THE- IT
DOESN'T FAVOR IF YOU ARE ON THE
PHONE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO FURTHER.
THANK YOU COMMENTED ILLEGAL
COMIC HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANYONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. XENON
MODERATOR PLEASE PROP THOSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION BY PHONE. AND FOR
THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
TO JUST BE ONE MOMENT.
WE DO HAVE A LINE JESSICA
STENDER ONE MOMENT PLEASE. A
QUICK REMINDER A TO THOSE
COLLEEN AND PLEASE ONLY STATE
YOUR NAME AND POSITION ON THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU. JESSICA PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I GUESS ACOSTA UNDER
ON BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT. YEAH.
NEXT WE GO TO SCOTT EMERGED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER BOB
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWENTY CHILL NOT SURE OF THE
TIME ON THE PENINSULA BOB.
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THE HOUSE OF THE CHEMICAL
LAWYERS SAYS. AND MORE THAN.
TEN CLARA SAN SOMETHING
CHAPTERS THANK YOU. WE GO TO
RYAN SHERMAN GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON WHICH RANGE FROM
RIVER SHERIFF'S LOCATION OR
STRONG SUPPORT AND BILL WE HAVE
HOPE ALL FORMS OF PRIVATE
PRISONS AND DETENTION CENTERS.
MODERATOR HUNTING LINES TO. WE
HAVE THREE MORE THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME PLACE TO CHILL
GO AHEAD. HEY LISA CHIU ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NEXT WE HAVE CHRIS L. GREW EAST
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. ANGER SHALL GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS CHRIS OVERLY THAT
THE IMMIGRANT LEGAL RESOURCE
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT. AND
WE HAVE ONE LAST ONE EVAN
MINTON GO AHEAD. HEY THIS IS
EVIN MEN CAN LOOK LIKE HER
PROGRESS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I AM GET ONE FOR
JACKIE GONZALEZ GO AHEAD.
EXACTLY GONZALEZ IMMIGRANT AND
ADVOCATES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR QUE NO OTHERS FOR
CLARIFICATION PURPOSES I HAD US
FOR OPPOSITION AND WE HEARD
SUPPORT- WE APOLOGIZE FOR THE
DELAY IN THE SYSTEM BUT I WANT
TO GIVE THOSE THE OPPORTUNITY-
TO WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ONCE AGAIN- CAN YOU PROMPT
THOSE WAITING ON THE LINE IF
THERE'S ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO
SPEAK. NOW I KNOW. TO THIS TIME.
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE WILL
ONE DAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THAT I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
THOSE TESTIFYING- AT THIS TIME
WE WANT TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION DO ANY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WISHING TO SPEAK ARE YOU MAY DO
SO AT THIS TIME BUT BEFORE WE
DO SO. A QUICK REMINDER OF THE
DELAYS PLEASE SPEAK INTO THE
MICROPHONE I WILL RECOGNIZE
pCHAIR- I'M AWARE OF THE ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE PRIVATE
FACILITIES AND I PLAN TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL I WAS JUST
CURIOUS AND READING IT. THE
ISSUE HAVING TO DO WITH SELF
INSURANCE. BUT GIVEN THE RATHER
RIGOROUS REQUIREMENTS THAT WE
SET OUT FOR COMPANIES TO SELF
INSURE WHICH IS AS I RECALL
INCLUDED BONDS AND A BUNCH OF
OTHER. ISSUES HAVE THERE BEEN
PROBLEMS WITH THESE PRIVATE
FACILITIES AND THEI WORKERS
COMPENSATION COVERAGE THOSE
THAT. HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
QUALIFY. AS SELF INSURED
EMPLOYERS FOR PURPOSES OF
WORKERS COMP. MMHM I DON'T KNOW
THE ANSWER TO THAT COULD I CALL
ON ONE OF OUR WITNESSES- FROM
THE AGE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
INSURANCE. YES TO ME. LET'S
MAKE IT A BRIEF PLEASE YES
THANK YOU MICHAEL MARTINEZ HERE
FOR CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SENATOR AND- JUST KNOW
THAT WERE IN THE BILL OF BEING
PROPOSED THESE FACILITIES ARE
PROHIBITED ROM SELF INSURING.
THAT WE JUST FELT THAT
IMPROVING SELF INSURANCE IT
ONLY AS A PERTAINS TO THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION LINE THAT
IT- PROTECTS CONTRACTING
AGENCIES WHO MAY BE LIABLE IF
FACILITY BECOMES INSOLVENT AND
LEAVES UNFUNDED LIABILITIES AND
SO THAT LEAST THAT WAS THE
POLICY REASON FOR HAVING THAT
TO THAT TECH COME. BROWSE BUT
BUILT AND WITH. TO AS TODAY FOR
ARE ANY ISSUES ALONG THESE
LINES OF WORKERS COMPENSATION
WOULD HAVE TO FOLLOW UP WITH
YOU IN YOUR OFFICE AFTER THIS
HEARING WELL AS I SAID I'M
GONNA VOTE FOR THE BILL OF
RIGHTS IT TO THE EXTENT.
PERMITTED BRINGS. BACK CHECK ON.
THE RECORD BUTTON WHETHER THE
BOND ISSUE TO COVER THE LAB IT
TALK ABOUT AN ALSO MY REC IS
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE AN UNINSURED
EMPLOYERS FUND IN THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION ARENA WHICH COVERS
THE LIABILITY SO THERE
SHOULDN'T BE ANY LIABILITY FOR
CONTRACTING ENTITY BUT- AS OF
MAY THE- PROVISIONS REMAIN IN
THE CODE I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY GET TO STAY
THERE. AND THAT WE DON'T TO.
WE'RE NOT SHOOTING AT THINGS
THAT DON'T EXIST SO THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR OF THE SUPPORTING
THE BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE WISHING
TO SPEAK MISTER MOORE LOCK YOU
MAY PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I I'VE HEARD IT IN THE
SENATORS OPENING REMARKS BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF I UNDERSTAND IT
YET SO- SHE MENTIONED- CENTER
YOU MENTION A. B. THIRTY TWO.
WHICH ABOLISHED THE FOR PROFIT.
PRISON INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA I
THOUGHT YOU SAID SOMETHING.
ELSE I'M JUST KIND OF CURIOUS.
IF YOU COULD REPEAT THAT IN AND
HELP ME OUT. ON WHY WE'RE-
DOING THIS BILL IF IT THIS
PARTICULAR INDUSTRY IS. BUT
EVEN SUPPOSED TO BE HERE. THERE
THE DATE- MAKE SURE MISSING
HERE. AFTER A JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY WAS THE EFFECTIVE
DATE OF AB THIRTY TWO- AND
UNFORTUNATELY PRIOR TO THAT-
SEVERAL COMPANIES IN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ABOUT
ENTERED INTO A SERIES OF
AGREEMENTS AND. BASICALLY THOSE
THOSE FACILITIES WILL CONTINUE
TO EXIST FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
THEY EXTENDED THE LENGTH OF
TIME- AND- SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE COVER THEM AS MUCH THAT
WAS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT IT DIDN'T INCLUDE
ANYBODY BECAUSE IT WAS AN
EFFECTIVE UNTIL JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY MEANWHILE A LOT
OF CONTRACTS WERE ENTERED INTO
IN THE FACILITIES CONTINUE TO
EXIST. SUBMITTED BY SHE'S BEEN
MANAGER. IF I WERE TO ROUTE TO
LOOK INTO IT A. B. THIRTY TWO
IT WOULD SAY THAT THE EFFECTIVE
DATE IS JANUARY ONE. TWENTY
UNLESS CONTRACTS HAVE BEEN
EXTENDED OUT FURTHER. SO THERE
IS WELCOME LOOPHOLE OR IT WOULD
BE AT EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY AS I UNDERSTAND
IT- AND SO THOSE CONTRACTS.
THAT WERE EXTENDED BEFORE THAT
TIME PERIOD OF COURSE WOULD
CONTINUE TO EXIST BECAUSE THE
EFFECTIVE DATE WASN'T UNTIL
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR THANK
ADVENTURE. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK PLEASE
DO SO AT THIS TIME. WE DON'T
HAVE ANY REMOTE COMMENTS- SOLD
OUT THANK YOUSENATOR ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AB
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL. THANK
YOU MOVE BY AM I AM MR GLAZER.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND YOU
TO TAKE A POTS AND LET THE
MICROPHONES BE TURNED ON THANK
YOU. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS RUBIO. AYE
RUBIO AYE JONES. NO JONES NO
ARCHULETA. HI ARCHULETA AYE
DODD. I DODD AYE GALGIANI AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE GLAZER
AYE HUESO HI HI SO I MITCHELL.
HI MITCHELL AYE MORE LOOK NO
MORE LIKE NO PORTANTINO I.
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. HI ROTH ON.
THE BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES IN
FAVOR TO AGAINST. THAT BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
TO RUSSELL WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY. NEXT WE WILL MOVE ON
TO SB EIGHT SEVENTY TWO BY
SENATOR DOT. MR DOT WHEN YOU'RE
READY YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. YOUR BROWN FIRE
SEASONS IN THE DEVASTATING
FIRES OF RECENT YEARS HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED FOR
CLARIFICATIONS TO INCREASE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS REGARDING
PROPERTY INSURANCE. SB EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
CLARIFICATIONS IT PROTECTIONS
FOR VICTIMS OF INSURED LOSSES
AFTER DECLARE DISASTERS IN
SEVERAL IMPORTANT WAYS. FIRST
WHAT IS SURE TO HAVE SUFFERED A
TOTAL LOSS AFTER DECLARED
DISASTER THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE INSURERS. TO MAKE IT
IMMEDIATE ADVANCE PAYMENT FOR
CONTENTS IN A LD. OF AT LEAST
25% OF THE INSURED'S CONTENT
POLICY LIMIT. A AT FOUR MONTHS
OF THEIR HOUSING IN A LEAVE
WITHOUT SUBMITTING. WAIT THE
ITEMIZE- INVENTORY OF ONE'S
BELONGINGS THIS SIMPLY MOVES UP
PAYMENTS INSURERS WOULD ALREADY
BE MAKING IT WOULD NOT LET ME
REPEAT THIS WOULD NOT RESULT IN
INCREASED PREMIUMS. IT ALSO
PROVIDES A SIXTY DAY GRACE
PERIOD FOR PREMIUM PAYMENTS IN
THE EVENT OF A STATE OF
EMERGENCY. IT ALSO CLARIFIES
THAT WHEN AN INSURED CHOOSES TO
PURCHASE A HOME RATHER THAN
REBUILD. THE INSURER CANNOT
DEDUCT THE LAND VALUE INCLUDED
THE PRICE OF THE NEW HOME FROM
THE ABOUT THE PAY THE INSURED.
THIS IS NOT AN EXTREMELY COMMON
OCCURRENCE SO AGAIN IT WOULD
ABSOLUTELY NOT DRIVE PREMIUM
COSTS. SOME OF FRAME PARTS OF
THIS BILL IS EXPANDING WHAT
POLICIES COVERED BUT THIS IS
SIMPLY NOT THE CASE. THE CHANGE
OF LANGUAGE IN SECTION TWO OH
FIVE ONE POINT FIVE REGARDING
TIME LIMITS TO COLLECT FULL
REPLACEMENT VALUE REVERTS TO
THAT SECTION TO PREPAY. TWENTY
NINETEEN LANGUAGE TO SAY THAT
IT COVERS COMMERCIAL AND
RESIDENTIAL POLICIES NOT JUST
RESIDENTIAL. COVERING BOTH
POLICIES IS HOW THE DEPARTMENT
IS ALWAYS INTERPRETER.
INTERPRETED AND ENFORCED THIS
SECTION. THIS IS THE CHANGE IN
LANGUAGE IN SECTION TWENTY
SIXTY FOR EXAMPLE DISCUSSING
NON COMMERCIAL LIVESTOCK IS
SIMPLY CLARIFYING WHAT THE
POLICY IS A BIG COVERING TO
AVOID NEEDLESS VIEW CONFUSION.
PROVIDING THESE ADDITIONAL
CLARIFICATIONS A PROTECTIONS
FOR CONSUMERS WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RELIEF AND
SAFEGUARDS TO INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR- I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
HAVE A WITNESS HERE- WISHING TO
SPEAK UP IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
THE GALLERY YOU MADE SPEAK AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL
MARTINEZ HERE ON BEHALF OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE JUST AT WHEN. ON A INITIAL
ELECTION TO OFFICE THE
COMMISSION WENT UP AND DOWN THE
STREET AND MET WITH COUNTLESS
OF INDIVIDUALS ESPECIALLY-
WILDFIRE SURVIVORS AND ONE
THING THAT HE HEARD CONSTANTLY
IN HEARING STORIES FROM
DEVASTATED- THOSE IMPACTED BY
THESE DEVASTATED. DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES WITH LOSING A HOME OR
BEING IN IT UNABLE TO RESIDE IN
ONE'S HOME FOR AN EXTENDED
PERIOD OF TIME. AND SO THIS
BILL. IT'S FAIR AND REASONABLE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AND
PROVIDES CLARIFICATIONS NEEDED
TO HELP EASE THE BURDEN. FOR
HOMEOWNERS AND RENTERS AS THEY
REBUILT THEIR HOMES ALLIES
AFTER A MAJOR CATASTROPHIC
EVENT. IN CLOSING JUST KNOW
THAT THESE ARE ALL IMPORTANT.
ACTIONS FOR CONSUMERS AND
REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU AND
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS WITH INTERESTED
STAKEHOLDERS AS THIS BILL MOVES
THROUGH THE PROCESS I DO HAVE A
COLLEAGUE ON ON THE PHONE WITH
ME TONY CIGNA RALLY A DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER FOR CONSUMER
SERVICES MARKET CONTACT SHOULD
THERE BE ANY- MORE TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT
THERE'S ABOUT SIXTY SECONDS
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
CAN ANYONE ELSE THE MODERATOR
PLEASE PUMP THOSE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT BY PHONE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THIS IS THE OPERATOR.
ANY LINE SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE MOMENT. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES STACEY HEATING RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NINE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ROBERT WHO RELEVANT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA WELL WE SUPPORT SB
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO AND THANK THE
AUTHOR OF FOR HIS EFFORTS ARE
GOING BACK A NUMBER OF YEARS IN
THIS AREA. AN IMPORTANT NOTE
THAT IT IS UNLIMITED AS A
REMINDER I'M SORRY TO INTERRUPT
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
POSITION ONLY THANK YOU. MODERN
CAN WE PROMPT THOSE WAITING ON
THE LINE ONCE AGAIN. BETTER
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. GEN
REMINDING EVERYONE PLEASE TO
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
POSITION ON THIS ISSUE. THERE
ARE NO FURTHER. SUPPORT LINE
THANK YOU FOR THAT. NOW CAN WE
PLEASE- PROMPT THE LINE FOR
THOSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS ISSUE. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS ISSUE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. MY NUMBER EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'M SURE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
MARK BACK ON WHAT THE AMERICAN
PROPERTY CHAPLAIN
TRANSPORTATION THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TELL BUT I
TELEPHONE ABOUT CUT BY BY PHONE
BECAUSE I USED TO LIVE IN THE
STATE OF ALASKA WITHOUT A DOUBT
THEIR DIFFERENT OPINIONS ABOUT
WHETHER NOT PICK COULD. WITHIN
TENDED TO APPLY THE CLERK WILL
COVER JUST AS STRONGLY DISAGREE
WITH THE INTENT OF THE TWO
THOUSAND FOUR KILL BILL WAS TO
INCLUDE COMMERCIAL BUT THAT
WOULD INVOLVE THE TRAPPED IN
THE BILL CAN I INTERJECT FOR
BUT A SECOND I'VE BEEN TOLD BY
MEMBERS THAT THEY'RE HAVING A
HARD TIME HEARING JUST STOP
REMINDING YOU TO SPEAK SLOWLY.
AND AS A REMINDER THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION THREE MINUTES TOTAL.
VALUE MAKE ANYA. THANK YOU
MA'AM. I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
THE DISCUSSIONS DURING THE TWO
THOUSAND KILLED WERE ENTIRELY
TO READ THAT PROPERTY BECAUSE
STANDING UP FIRE CALMLY WILL
HAVE WEST OF THE COVERAGES. WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE INTENT
OF THAT STATURE WAS TO ACQUIRE
TO COMMERCE IS NEW AT THAT ALL
CORD OF THE DRUG LAND IN ALL OF
THE- AND A WHAT STATION WITH
THE I THINK NOW OF THE LA AT
THE A COVER. ABOUT IT AND THE
CO COVERAGE OF HOW WE RESPECT
AND PUBLIC QUITE A COMMERCIAL
ONE ONE OF THE CLEARLY BUT. IT
THE HOLD FACTS ABOUT REBUILDING.
WHAT BROUGHT. BY APOLLO OLDER
WILL BE HOME BURKE TO LOOK INTO
AND DID NOT WANT TO LOOK AT THE-
BUT BURGER THREE TIMES. I WOULD
NEVER THOUGHT THAT THIS. MAY A
POP PLY THE CARDINAL PROP. THE
COMMITTEE WISHES DON'T OF THE
BUCK MUCH PROPERTY. IT SHOULD
BE OUT OF SEPARATE SECTION ONE
ANOTHER FOR WHAT CONDITIONS.
APPROPRIATE FOR MY PROP. I HAVE
TO ADMIT THAT I'VE BEEN TRYING
TO GET MY- BY COMMERCIAL. FOCUS
ON BILL BUT IF YOU KNOW
COMMERCIAL. AND CHARGES MAY I
HAVE THE STORE OF THE WAY OF
THE- TWENTY THIS OPEN UP CHARTS
WORKERS PREAMP OF THE TIME WAVE
OF. WE'RE STARTING TO SEE A NOT
GOTTEN STREET BY WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK THE- ANOTHER. IN ALL
ASPECTS. THE BILL CARMELLA
MANDATORY. ANY POLICY TOLD. BY
AFTER CREE MISTER. COMPANY
SHOULD TO. GREG BY THE PUBLIC
SHARKS. SECTION NEEDS TO BE A
TO REQUIRE. IN COMPANIES ALSO
GRAY. THIS MANDATORY. THANK YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TODAY THANK
YOU FOR THAT ONE MINUTE LET AYE
BUT THERE'S SO TAYLOR THE PHONE.
WE DO HAVE A LINE NUMBER THREE
PLEASE AHEAD. GOT IT THANK GOOD
AT MEMBERS TELL WITH THE PUSH
INJURY FEDERATION. WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT BUT STATE TODAY
HOPE YOU ALL DOING WELL. ON
FOR. WE MUST OF SPH TWO. WE
CONSISTENTLY COMPRESSOR ABOUT
IMPORTANCE OF HOMEOWNERS
INSURANCE. BUT THIS BILL WILL.
MAKE INSURANCE MORE EXPENSIVE.
THEY CANNOT BE THE CASE THAT
THIS BILL HELPS CONSUMERS BUT
SOMEHOW DOES NOT AFFECT COSTS.
BY EXPANDING THE CIRCUMSTANCES
UNDER WHICH ADDITIONAL LIVING
EXPENSE RENTS ARE REQUIRED. AND
REDUCING THE LEVEL OF SCRUTINY
FOR CAN'T CLAIMS. THIS MEASURE
WILL INCREASE CLAIMS AND LOSSES
WHICH IN TURN FOR MYSELF
INSURANCE COSTS WHILE
CALIFORNIANS THERE WE ARE. THAT
ABSENT DIRECTION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. TO
APPROVE ADEQUATE RATE. THAT
REFLECT THE NEW COSTS IMPOSED
BY THE BILL THEY MAY ALSO
EXACERBATE THE HOMEOWNER'S
INSURANCE AVAILABILITY
CHALLENGES. AND HIGH FIRE IS
SCARY SO THE STATE WHICH IS
ANOTHER ISSUE OF GREAT CONCERN
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE SHOULD
KNOW ABOUT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
FOR THAT CAN WE GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY WISHING TO
SPEAK. IN OPPOSITION TWENTY
FORTY. SEEN AT NON- UP
MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT TOLL
STILL WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. ONCE AGAIN. ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME ON YOUR FROM. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. NINE FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS SHERRY
MCCUE REPRESENTING THE
NEGATIVITY ATION OF. ANY I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE EIGHT.
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION MINE. THANK YOU-
HEARING NO FURTHER- COMMENTARY
NOW I WANT TO OPEN IT MEMBERS
TO ANY BODY WISHING TO SPEAK
YOU MAY DO SO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER MOORE LOCK YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM HAIR I
JUST WANT TO TRY AND RESOLVE
THIS DEBATE. SENATOR DODD YOU
SAID THIS WOULD NOT RAISE
PREMIUMS BUT I'M GETTING
ARGUMENTS BACK THAT IT WILL
RAISE PREMIUM SO. TO ME GIVE ME
A LITTLE TUTORIAL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. CARE FIRST OF ALL. I
FEEL LIKE I'M A VETERAN OF
DOING THESE INSURANCE BILLS AS
A RESULT OF WILDFIRES I DID IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN LAST YEAR
AND HERE AGAIN THIS YEAR AND
WHATEVER THERE IS AN INSURANCE
BILL THE REASON WHY INSURANCE
COMPANIES BUT OPPOSE THESE
BILLS SAY IT'S CAN IMPOSE COST-
IT'S GOOD OPPOSE COST ON YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AND GET. GET THAT
LEGISLATORS THE ALL ALL HOT AND
BOTHERED ABOUT THAT SIMPLY PUT
WE'RE GONNA GO THROUGH THE
THREE AGAIN NUMBER ONE. WHAT
ENSURE TO SUFFERED A TOTAL LOSS
AFTER DECLARED DISASTER.
BASICALLY THERE IT WE'RE ASKING
THEM TO PAY 25% OF IT IT
INSURANCE CAR TAX POLICY LIMIT
IT FOR MONTHS BAILEY. THEY'RE
GOING TO PAY A 100% OF THAT
WE'RE JUST ASKING FOR CASH FLOW
FOR THESE VICTIMS THAT HAVE
LOST EVERYTHING. EVERYTHING IN
THEIR LIFE THEY'VE LOST ALL
WE'RE SAYING IS PLEASE FOR THEM
25% OF THE TOTAL AMOUNT THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO GET ANYWAY
THAT DOES NOT INCREASE COSTS.
SECOND THE SIXTY DAY GRACE
PERIOD FOR PREMIUM PAYMENT IN
THE EVENT OF AN EMERGENCY
PEOPLE ON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE
THEIR CHECK MAYBE THEY DON'T
EVEN HAVE A CHECKBOOK ANYMORE.
THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THE
NUMBER OF YOUR ACCOUNTS ARE
THEY NEED A GRACE PERIOD- THIS
MAY. PRESENT A MINIMAL WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT THIS IS JUST NOW.
ANYBODY THAT'S A VICTIM OF A
THAT. OF A- FIRE THAT IS A
FEDERAL AND STATE DECLARED
EMERGENCY SO IT'S A FINITE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE LET'S JUST SAY
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. THAT
WAS LIKE. WHAT TWO THOUSAND
PEOPLE PERHAPS THE SIX THREE
THOUSAND OVER TWELVE MILLION
INSURERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. I JUST THINK
THAT THAT IS ABSOLUTELY DE
MINIMUS. FINALLY THE LAST
PROVISION IS WHAT ENSURE
CHOOSES TO PURCHASE A HOME
RATHER THAN REBUILD. THE
INSURER CANNOT DETECT THE LAND
VALUE INCLUDED IN THE PRICE
HERE'S MY EXAMPLE. LET'S JUST
SAY YOU'VE GOT A ONE POINT TWO.
MILLION DOLLAR HOUSE. THE
REALITY IS. IF YOU REBUILD IT
IT IN IT IT'S INSURED THROUGH
THE YOU CAN REBUILD THAT HOUSE
FOR A MILLION DOLLARS ON LAND
VALUE IS TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
THEY'RE GONNA WRITE YOU A CHECK
FOR TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO BE. PART OF ME
THEY'RE GONNA WRITE YOU A CHECK
FOR A MILLION DOLLARS THE TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND STAYS THERE
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE LED.
TO BUILD YOUR HOUSE ON. BUT IN
ANOTHER SIS'S SITUATION BUT SAY
THEY DECIDE HEY YOU KNOW WHAT
WE- WERE OLDER WE DON'T WANT TO
GO THROUGH AND REBUILD OUR HOME
OR I'M GONNA GO TO AN OLD FOLKS
HOME OR- SENIOR CITIZENS THAT'S
TERRIBLE THINGS. SEE YOUR BILL
THE SINCE SENIOR CITIZEN.
CELERY IN IT AND NOT HAVE TO
REBUILD MY HOME. WHAT THEY WANT
TO DO THAT IS TO WRITE A CHECK
FOR A MILLION DOLLARS NOW THEY
WANT TO WRITE YOU A CHECK FOR
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND. HOW
FAIR IS THAT. SO I'M TELLING
YOU OF SIX YEAR OLD IN IN TERMS
OF THIS PARTICULAR BILL THIS
WILL NOT INCREASE COSTS- I AM
VERY VERY SENSITIVE TO INCREASE
COST PARTICULARLY IN THIS DAY
AND AGE RIGHT. NOW WITH THE
COVERT SITUATION BUT THAT THIS-
I JUST REALLY WHAT WE'RE
HEARING. WHAT'S WRONG EVERY IN
ALL IT'S TO GET A LITTLE BIT
MORE. FOR CONSUMERS. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK. I WILL NOW GIVE US
SENATOR BATES THAT WHOSE- THE
CITY REMOTELY AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ARE WELCOME SENATOR BATES
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN MAKE
SURE I'M DOING THIS THING RIGHT
TIME I THINK THE AFFORDABILITY
ISSUE CONTINUES TO BE VERY
PERPLEXING WHEN WE HEAR ENATOR
DODD I SAY IT IS NOT HAPPY
AWESOME INSURANCE AND WANT TO
BELIEVE THAT HOWEVER OP MY
DISTRICT HAS SOME VERY HIGH
RISK FIRE AREAS AND IN FACT THE
PREMIUMS HAVE GONE UP. SO I
THINK IT WOULD BE IMPORTANT TO
HEAR FROM MR MARTINO IF THEY
HAVE DONE ANY SORT OF COST IN
OUR SCHOOLS AND MAY THAT SHOULD
BE SOMETHING THAT WE ASK FOR SO
WE DON'T EACH. REALLY THE ISSUE
I USED THE BILL I AND WE'RE ALL
VERY KIND. ESPECIALLY IF THEY
DON SAID THE BOB AND THE A-
THAT CAR STAR. COSTS THIRTY
WILL UP A LOT OF WITH INSURANCE
AND- IN MY DISTRICT. WHERE
PEOPLE OF HAD TO SEEK YOU KNOW
AD SOME YOU KNOW VERY VERY
DIFFICULT TIME OTHER INSURANCE.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN
DISCONTINUED OR THE COSTS AS
BEEN PRO CANADA. BECAUSE OF
WHAT HAPPENED DURING THE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND THAT THE
BIG WILD FIRE SEASON SO.
WITHOUT MISTER MARTINEZ IF YOU
WOULD. HAVE YOU DONE AN
ANALYSIS WHAT DO YOU DO AN
ANALYSIS ON THE COST IMPACTS
WHEN WE EXPAND- CLAIMS OF LOS
EXPERIENCES OR EXPENSES AND IF
NOT- AND CHEER I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING WE SHOULD CONSIDER
GOING FORWARD. THAT WE DO ASK
FOR PREMIUM IMPACTS THE MATCH
AN ANALYSIS ON ALTHOUGH THE
BILLS THAT ARE SPONSORED BY CD
I THAT IS SO SIMPLY I THINK
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE PART
OF- WHAT WE TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT
WE'RE DETERMINING SUPPORT. FOR
THESE BILLS WHICH HEY I AM
TOTALLY THERE ARE FOR THE
CONSUMERS THAT WE HAVE TO
ASSUME THAT OTHER PEOPLE YOU
KNOW ARE ARE BEING SEEING
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED. ON
EVERY FRONT SUBTLE WITHOUT TIME
BY TO ASK IF YOU WOULD ASK
MISTER MARTINEZ TO GIVE US SOME
INSIGHT ON YOUR- WHETHER THERE
IS A COST ANALYSIS THAT GOES.
ALONG WITH EACH BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES MARCH FOR JULY TO
RESPOND TO THAT YES OF COURSE.
MICHAEL MARTINEZ DEL APARTMENT
INSURANCE THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES FOR THAT QUESTION. AND
THERE IS A MEMBER WAY TO US TO
ANSWER THIS AND THEN A MICRO
LET ME. JUST SAY FROM THE MICRO
FIRST WITH REGARD TO THIS BILL
SENATE BILL EIGHT SEVEN TWO
BEFORE THIS BODY. IS THAT ON
PAGE SIX OF NINE FOR THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THERE IS A
REFERENCE TO THE DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE STAFF. PROVIDING A
BASIC ASSESSMENT OF THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT THIS BILL MAY
HAVE ON RATES. AND SO I WANTED
TO POINT TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO THE SECTION. WHERE
BASICALLY IT STATED THAT. MANY
OF THE EXPEDITED CLAIMS
PROVISIONS IN TIME WOMEN EXPECT
EXTENSIONS. SHOULD NOT IMPACT
RATES SIGNIFICANTLY BECAUSE-
THEY ONLY PROVIDE WITH INSURED
WOULD HAVE RECEIVED ANYWAY. I
ALSO LIKE TO SAY THAT.
PREVIOUSLY THERE ARE SEVERAL
COMPONENTS OF THIS BILL. THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE FOR
THE LAST THREE YEARS WHEN WE'VE
HAD THESE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES. HAS EL REACHED TO
THROUGH NOTICES TO THE
INSURANCE. INDUSTRY IS SAYING
HEY CAN YOU EXPEDITE CLAIMS CAN
YOU- PROVIDE AN UP FRONT. ON
THE A LEE PAYMENT CAN YOU DO
AGAIN THE SERIES OF THINGS.
WHICH THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY WE
THANK FOR RISING TO THE
OCCASION AND THEY THEY ABIDED
BY THAT. AND AGAIN MUST ADMIT
AT A- HAD VOLUNTARILY. AND SO
THE RISK OF ALL THESE
COMPONENTS THAT. AGAIN FOR THE
LAST FEW YEARS THAT WE'VE HAD
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES. THAT
INSURERS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
PROVIDE IT TO THEIR POLICY
HOLDERS AND WE THINK THAT'S
THAT'S AGAIN THAT'S GOOD
BUSINESS AND THAT THEY HAVE
DONE SO I DID WANT TO DISTANCE
A FROM. FOR PROVIDING A BASIC
ASSESSMENTTHE DEPARTMENT TO
PROVIDE ONE. AND I'D ALSO SAY
IN CLOSING THIS MICRO ASPECT
THE SAVINGS FROM EXPERTS CLAIM
SETTLEMENT AND LOWER ALIE COSTS
RELATED TO THE CLAIM. CAN
ACTUALLY OFFSET ANY ADDITIONAL
LOSSES. BY BY THIS EXPANSION.
THANK YOU MISTER MARTINEZ- AS
ANY OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK. UP MISTER GLAZER YOU MAY
PROCEED. I THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IS WORKING. I WANT
TO REMIND YOU TO SPEAK INTO
YOUR MICROPHONE PLEASE THANK
YOU I AM SEEKING AND THERE WE
GO OKAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
CERTAINLY THE SENATOR FROM NAPA
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE AND WHEN
THE- POINTS THAT HE MADE ABOUT
THE REFORMS IN THE- PROPOSAL.
IMPACT ON BECAUSE I WANTED TO
GIVE THE- THE OPPONENTS SO
ANOTHER CHANCE TO. SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY TO THE ELEMENTS IN
WHICH THE SENATOR HAS AS REYES.
AND THE CONCLUSIONS THAT HE HAS
REACHED AGAIN. MANY OF THEM
SEEM PRETTY REASONABLE. BUT TO
ME AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE I
I'VE I'VE HEARD UNDERSTAND THEM
CORRECTLY FROM ALL SIDES. IS
THERE ANY UPON WISHING TO SPEAK
AT THIS TIME. ON THAT ISSUE.
MODERATOR PLEASE UP PROMPT THE
LINE FOR ANYONE WISHING TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE. AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
DO HAVE. A COMMENT FROM NINE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY HALEY YEAH SPEAKERS. SORRY
ABOUT THAT YES THIS IS SHERRY
CALIF OF PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION AGAIN I JUST I MEAN
YOU HAVE TO POINT OUT THE IN
CONFLUENCE OF THE NOTION THAT
SOMEHOW CONSUMERS ARE GOING TO
BENEFIT FROM HAVING THESE
ADDITIONAL PAYMENTS YET THERE'S
NO FINANCIAL IMPACT IF INSURERS
ARE ALREADY DOING ALL THIS AS
IS BEING SUGGESTED. AND WHAT IS
THE NECESSITY FOR THE BILL.
CLEARLY RIGHT NOW BY SAYING
THAT PEOPLE ARE YOU'RE HAVING
TO DO UP TO THREE YEARS OF
LIVING EXPENSES FOR SOMEONE
WHO'S ALWAYS NOT EVEN DAMAGED.
BECAUSE OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT'S DAMAGED BECAUSE SAY P.
JEANNIE CAN'T GET THEIR POWER
LINES BACK UP OR CITY DECIDED
TO USE CHEAP PLASTIC PIPES
INSTEAD OF STEEL FOR THEIR
WATER MAIN. THAT COULD BE TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE. WITH NO
DAMAGE TO THEIR HOME- NOW
INSURERS ARE PAYING THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS A MONTH FOR THEIR
LIVING EXPENSES. AND IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IN THE CATASTROPHE
TO BACK THAT YOU TO THAT. THAT
COULD BE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS A MONTH.
ILLUSTRATIVE PURPOSES SO TO
THINK THAT THERE'S NO POTENTIAL
IMPACT TO DOING THAT TYPE OF
EXPANSION. IT IS- IT'S NOT IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE- AGAIN AND
AS NOTED WHAT THE LAND VALUE.
DEDUCTION ISSUE SOME INSURERS
DO THAT NOW SOME DO NOT SO FOR
THE ONES WHO DO NOT THAT IS NOW
A NEW EXPENSE. AND BY NOT
SCRUTINIZING CLEANS EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE PRESUMING THAT MUCH OF
THESE COSTS LIKE WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN PAID FOR NOW SKIPPING AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THE PROCESS BY
WHICH WE SCRUTINIZE AND ENSURE.
THAT THE CLAIMS WERE GETTING A
BALLOT IN THE MOTIVATIONS ARE
CERTAINLY MERITORIOUS PEOPLE
ARE TO DISASTER WE WANT TO
SERVE THEM QUICKLY AND INSURERS.
WANTED IN THAT. BUT YOU STILL
HAVE TO HAVE SOME CHECKS AND-
TO DETERMINE OUT YOUR ROBERT
YOU'RE GONNA PLEASE. YOU HAVE A
FEW MORE SECONDS REV UP YOUR
COMMENTS PLEASE. OKAY THANKS
THAT'S WHAT I WAS GONNA SAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THIS DEBATE- IF I
UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY IT WAS
SENATOR MITCHELL WHO- MADE A
MOTION. TO MOVE THE BILL.
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK
RESTAURANTS. THANK YOU I'M SURE
I'D LIKE TO GET A LITTLE MORE
CLARIFICATION FROM THE
GENTLEMAN WHO JUST SPOKE. MY
QUESTION IS THIS WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF YOUR LOSS CLAIMS
INVOLVE A PROPERTY OWNER. WHO
ELECTS NOT TO REBUILD BUT
RATHER TO PURCHASE ANOTHER
PROPERTY OR NOT PURCHASE
ANYTHING AT ALL WHICH WOULD
TRIGGER THE LAND VALUATION.
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE PROMPT
THE SPEAKER. IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE A
COMMENT FROM A LINE OF. THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU SENATOR I HAVE TO SAY AT
THIS AT THIS MOMENT I DO NOT
HAVE DATA ON HOW OFTEN THAT
HAPPENS- HOPEFULLY IT'S NOT
VERY OFTEN. OF COURSE NOW WE'RE
SEEING IT MORE AND MORE OFTEN
FOR EXAMPLE IN PARADISE. THERE
ARE A LOT MORE PEOPLE THAT
WANTED TO MOVE AWAY DID NOT
USUALLY. I DON'T HAVE I DO NOT
HAVE SPECIFIC DATE ON THAT
WHICH I THINK GOES BACK TO
SENATOR BASIS POINT ABOUT. THE
NOTION- REALLY STARTING TO HAVE
SOME SORT OF MORE A LIPSTICK
ANALYSIS OF THESE BILLS.
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S SENATOR
DODD NOTED WE DO FREQUENTLY
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION. AND FOR
EXAMPLE WE HAVE. ASSEMBLY BILL
YOUR BLOOM TO INCREASE-
BUILDING CODE UPGRADE. AND ALL
THE STATE IS CUMULATIVE HE
REALLY START TO ADD UP. AND
THERE'S NO ACCOUNTING BY THE
DEPARTMENT THAT SAYS HEY HERE'S
AN ANALYSIS WILL CRANK EVEN. IF
PANEL OUT THERE SO DON'T TAKE.
INSURANCE TREES WORD OR THE-
WORD. BUT MAYBE THERE'S AN FOR
ANY. LOOK AT WHAT IS THE REALLY
THE OVERALL IMPACT TO
CONSUMERS. BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
KEEP EXPANDING OUR BENEFITS AND
THINK THAT THERE'S NOT GOING TO
BE A COST IMPACT. BUT WITH
REGARDS TO YOUR SPECIFIC
QUESTION ON LAND VALUE
DEDUCTION I DON'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC STATUTORY ACT YOU. BUT
THE- THERE'S A POTENTIAL IMPACT.
FROM A. INTEREST PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ALL THESE
LITTLE THINGS CERTAINLY DO
START TO ADD UP INTO THE CLAIMS
IN LOS HISTORY THAT LEADS INTO
PREMIUMS ULTIMATELY. THANK YOU
MANAGER JUST TO FOLLOW UP THE
MISTER MARTINEZ MISTER MARTINEZ
DOES THE DEPARTMENT MAINTAIN
THAT DATA. AND MIKE MARTINEZ
HERE FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE I WOULD ASK KINDLY IF
MY COLLEAGUE TWENTY CIGNA
REALLY WHO ACTUALLY DOES HANDLE
THESE AREAS WITHIN HIS TEAM CAN
CUT CAN. RESPOND TO THIS. AND
DUE TO OUR TO OUR TIME
CONSTRAINTS ALLOW ANOTHER
THIRTY SECONDS TO RESPOND WE
HAVE ANOTHER COMMITTEE HEARING
AFTER THIS. GO AHEAD. OPERATOR
I'M SORRY- MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE PROP THE SPEAKER. THAT
LINE IS OPEN. YES AND THEN
SHARED SENATORS THIS IS TONY
SECURELY DEPUTY COMMISSIONER
FOR CONSUMER SERVICES WE DON'T
HAVE DIRECT DATA INDUSTRY WIDE
WITH REGARD TO HOW MANY. AND
SHE POLICY HOLDERS CHOOSE TO GO
AND PURCHASE A NEW HOME RATHER
THAN WHERE YOU BILL- WE DO HAVE
IT JUST IN THE SMALL UNIVERSE
OF THE NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS
THAT WE DO GET- IN THAT
UNIVERSE IT'S A RELATIVELY
SMALL NUMBER. BUT IT'S WITHIN
THOSE PEOPLE THAT DO NOT DECIDE
TO REBUILD THEY DO OBTAIN LESS
MONEY THAN HAD THEY WERE BUILT
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY FROM OUR POINT OF VIEW. SB
EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR JUST LEVELS
THE PLAYING FIELD WITH NO DRUG
DETRIMENT TO THE INSURANCE
COMPANY FOR SOME REASON BUT WE
DON'T HAVE TIME TO GO UNTIL
UNLESS YOU CHOOSE TO THANK YOU.
THING AROUND HERE. THANK YOU.
NOW WE'RE GONNA GO OVER TO A
SENATOR GLAZER. MADAM CHAIR I
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY I APPRECIATE THE- THE
GOOD INTENTIONS OF THE AUTHOR
AND THE SPONSORS TO- TO DO
RIGHT BY A PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
HEARD IN THIS FASHION BUT I DO
WANT TO RESERVE THE RIGHT TO RE
EXAMINE THAT IF I CAN GET CLEAR
FACTUAL INFORMATION. FROM THE
OPPONENTS ABOUT THE COST
IMPACTS DOWN THE GRANTED
THERE'S AN ABILITY TO THE RATE
PAID FOR RATE PROCESS TO ADD.
COST TO BE DA INCORPORATED AND
THE RATE INCREASES SO THERE IS
A REMEDY THERE. BUT I COULD
BEAT BUT BUT I DO THINK CAT
AGAIN THE FACTS. ON THE TABLE
ABOUT CLEAR COSTS. BASED ON
HISTORY WOULD BE AN IMPORTANT.
PART OF APPROPRIATE DECISION
MAKING AND I WOULD RESERVE THE-
ABILITY TO HAVE A DIFFERENT
VIEW OF THOSE FACTS WERE
BROUGHT FORWARD BUT OTHERWISE-
AS FOR THE BILL TODAY. THANK
YOU SENATOR. HAVING A DEBATE
SEES I BELIEVE- SENATOR
MITCHELL MOVED THE BILL OF THE
MOTION IS TO PASS MEMBERS
PLEASE REMEMBER TO SPEAK INTO
YOUR MIKE BEFORE VOTING-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RUBIO HI RUBIO I JONES. NO
JONES NO ARCHULETA HI.
ARCHULETA HI DODD. DODD HI
GALGIANI HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
HI GLAZER HI HUESO ALL RIGHT
HUESO HI MITCHELL. MORE LOOK NO
MORE LUCK NO PORTANTINO HI.
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH ROUGH TIME.
ROTH I'D. WELL EIGHT VOTES
THANK IT WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR AN ABSENT MEMBER AT
THIS TIME- I WANT TO JUST MAKE
A CLARIFICATION ON THE PREVIOUS
BILL. BILL SB TWELVE TWENTY TWO
DORADO- IT WAS OUT OF BY A VOTE
OF NINE TWO TWO WANTED TO MAKE
THAT CLARIFICATION. ONCE AGAIN
WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. WE WILL NOW
GO TO A TO MEASURES PROPOSED
FOR CONSENT TODAY. SB TWELVE
FIFTY FIVE THE COMMITTEE ON THE
BEST BILL AND SB ELEVEN NINETY
TWO MISTER BRADFORD TO I HAVE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SOME OF BY MISTER GLAZER. OR
SOMETHING AT THE END OF THE
MONTH SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTIONS ARE SB ELEVEN
NINETY TWO TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND SB TWELVE FIFTY
FIVE TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR LIKE. RUBIO HI RUBIO
HI JONES HI JONES HI ARCHULETA
HI. ARCHULETA HI DODD. DODD HI
GALGIANI. GALGIANI HI GLAZER HI
GLAZER HI HUESO HUESO HI
MITCHELL. MORE LOCK FIVE MORE
LUCK HI PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO HI BROUGHT. HI ROTH
BY. THE BILL HAS TEN VOTES.
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD A BILL. ALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU MEMBERS AT THIS POINT I
JUST WANT TO FOR THE- THOSE IN
OPPOSITION IN SUPPORT OF ANY OF
THE BILLS SAY WE WERE NOT ABLE
TO RECORD YOUR- YOUR NAME AND
YOUR OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT FOR
A BILL PLEASE GO TO OUR WEBSITE
MY ALWAYS US MEDI. MONEY ON THE
SITE TODAY BOY IT IS HEARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- WE
WILL LEAVE THE FEDERAL OPEN
FORTY UP TO MEMBER THANK YOU.
WE'LL TAKE A FIVE MINUTE
POLICIES.
WE ARE NOW GOING TO
LIFT THE CALL ON SB EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO DOT. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AS A MIKE
ON. OVER HERE. THIS ONE ON.
IT'S GOING TO A SHOWER CAP ON
SO WE CAN SHARE. SB EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO THE CURRENT VOTE IS
EIGHT TO TWO. I THOUGHT IT WAS.
ON SOMEONE WHO IS ON. OKAY SB
EIGHT TO THE CURRENT IS EIGHT
TO TWO METAL. MID JULY.
MITCHELL AYE THE BILL IS OUT
NINETY THREE NINETY TWO EXCUSE
ME. NOW WE'RE MOVING TO CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR SB TWELVE FIFTY
FIVE AND ELEVEN NINETY TWO BY
BRADFORD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CONSECUTIVE KERR VOTERS TEND TO
ZERO MITCHELL. MITCHELL LIVE.
MITCHELL AYE THE BILL IS OUT
ELEVEN ZERO. THANK YOU THANK
YOU TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY OUR OF REMOTELY
AND IN PERSON THIS IS ANY
PROCESS AND WE APOLOGIZE OF
ANYONE IF YOU MEAN OVER THE
PHONE EXPERIENCE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO US INTO THE
PROCESS IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE INSURANCE. OR
I'D LIKE TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
THEIR PATIENCE AND COOPERATION
IN THIS PROCESS AND THE SENATE
DESK AND IT STUFF THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ALL THE WORK AND
MAKING THE PUBLIC PROP- PROCESS
POSSIBLE DURING THIS-
UNPRECEDENTED TIME AT THIS
POINT THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
THIS IS A GIANT EVERYONE.